a lot of people are breaking up the ATF
thing because essentially what they're
calling for is going to make a lot of
Americans
felons just like the kind of bump stock
ban that passed through Donald Trump
that was just ruled unconstitutional so
other than the courts is there any way
to effectively Lobby the ATF is there
any way to stop them from from
essentially making legal law-abiding
citizens felons overnight one tool that
we got in these negotiations over the
speaker of the house is the
reinstitution of something called the
Homan rule where you can zero out the
funding for a particular bureaucrat so
like imagine if you could have just
isolated like fauci's salary and zeroed
it out and forced to vote on that
couldn't do that before you're now going
to be able to do that I suspect that
some of us in the Second Amendment
caucus will be visiting the uh the
bureaucrats at the ATF with that tool
Holmen
oh man we didn't even talk about fauci
see is he well loved in Congress is it
divisive what's what's his next gig
University president big Pharma CEO
podcast is going to be the CEO of Pfizer
how can he not right yeah yup something
like that yeah would you hire fauci if
you knew that no matter what job it was
he was going to be spending like
20 hours a week in Congressional
depositions I think he got a deal I'd be
willing to bet like so many of these
other uh officials who have this with
you know within this revolving door
system he probably could have deal a
long time ago that when he's out they'll
pick him up speaking of the revolving
door another one of the like ethics
things that I just don't understand how
it's not the law now if you are a member
of Congress you should never get to be a
lobbyist or a registered foreign agent
but it is like two of the most frequent
jobs that people get when they're done
with the job I have is literally being a
registered agent for a foreign
government or influencing people for
money and I don't I don't get why it's
not like a total Common Sense thing to
say like you've got to choose one path
or the other like you if you want to go
be a foreign agent if you want to get
paid money to influence outcomes then
that means you don't get to be one of
the lawmakers yeah yeah I believe it was
Joe Rogan a couple months ago was
interviewing someone that was making the
claim that members of Congress were
getting different kind of treatment for
covid than the rest of the general
public was do you know if that's
particularly true I know we talked about
this yeah um do you remember who the
guest was because I can't remember that
off the top of my head right now but
that was the accusation is that
accusation true that Congress gets a
different kind of Health Care system
than the American people do when it came
to covet nah man we're like most of us
are on the DC Obamacare Exchange
so you got Obamacare is it not Obama did
you get code what's up with this I hear
like members of Congress sleeping in
their office yeah uh more than a hundred
of the 435 members of Congress when
they're in uh Washington DC actually
live inside of their office and I did
that until I met my now wife and she
made it very clear that that was not an
arrangement that she was going to be
tolerant of just because they want to
save money uh it's it's the money uh I
mean a lot you know though no one should
ever worry about members of Congress in
our economic standing I mean people who
have you know maybe a spouse that
doesn't work that's raising a family you
know maintaining two residences on a
congressional salary is challenging for
some people I uh I mostly like Airbnb it
because uh I have the like Yasser Arafat
theory that you never want to sleep in
the same bed twice what's this what's
this what's this thing I'm hearing that
y'all are getting a 34 000 raise is that
true
uh no one's told me that there was an
article in the daily mail that said that
one of the last things the Democrats did
before the end of the last session was
put in a raise of thirty four thousand
dollars I'm unaware of any race if
that's true the Margaritas are on me
after the show Elon Musk probably is
going to like to hear that the members
of Congress are sleeping in their own
office uh but there's a lot of rodent
activity at night too because they're
always working on that building wow pay
bump there you go man to ask you about
this could give could give oh yeah no
that's a that's a per diem uh there's
Congress was like weirdly cut out of the
GSA per diem and so that would allow
Congress to access the the GSA per die
which is like while you're working away
from home your that'll be your budget
right so if like if I bring an employee
from Pensacola up to Washington to work
on a legislative issue for a week they
get a per diem but we don't so this
would equalize I was going to ask you
what do you think about what Elon Musk
is doing with Twitter and do you think
there's going to be any kind of
Retribution against stem since he did
expose how essentially the intelligence
agencies were pretty much running big
Tech social media is there going to be
like some bureaucratic investigations
are they going to try to take away some
of his funding from some of his
spaceships how do you think that's you
already saw Chris Murphy call for
reviews of the different foreign
investors in the musk Twitter deal so
it's not a question of if that will
happen that that is happening now it's
just a question of the level of Acuity
of it and and you know there's so many
of my Republican colleagues are like
yeah you know Twitter's ours now Elon
bought Twitter rah-rah you know wave the
pom-poms for Elon and I'm glad he bought
it I'm glad Twitter's more of a
democratized free speech speech space
but like is this what we is this what we
have to wait for that we have to wait
around for something like right-wing
billionaire to come buy stuff so that we
can have a playground I just don't want
to live in a world where the terms of
service on social media become more
important than the values that undergird
the constitution tuition yeah it's a
cultural question though right it just
seems like it seems so low T to sit
around and cheer on Elon well like we
are the board of directors the most
powerful country in the world and we do
nothing while the
digital Marketplace of ideas is Zapped
of any conservative thought yeah yeah I
don't think relying on any one guy is
the right move it's weight because his
emotions can change his behavior we say
he wouldn't let Alex Jones back on
because he's like no I don't like what
he said about kids about Sandy Hook
stuff like uh
started a story in New York I mean he
just bought the entire I don't know the
exact history but because of one
billionaire or whatever he was worth we
have Astoria and like we have
communities like one rich guy can build
a community it's a little culty but it's
kind of like the history of our of our
species I don't know if we need that
like I think that we can legislate away
the problems sometimes but a lot of
times I think it's in the private sector
I don't know like the government's
really good what I really love the
government for is to tell us when
something has gone too far and to stop
it from happening as opposed to making
all these things happen all the time
like that's up for the populace today
yeah but wouldn't you agree that
these tech companies getting more power
than most of the governments that have
ever existed in all of human history is
that threshold where they've gone too
far yes yes it's gone too far it needs
to be broken up in a way that I I think
needs to be novel that's right so then
the dispute among some working on the
issue is do you use like the force of
law to break them up or do you like
almost do what happened to the tobacco
companies in the 90s where you strip
their immunities and then sick the trial
lawyers on them well they're still
they're still acting in the benefit of a
lot of government agents I don't see
them being put in check until they stop
actually taking the orders from
government and not doing what the
government really wants them to do
um
litigating against them in court want
their next job to be at Big Tech you
know I mean the revolving door is kind
of a consistent theme of our of our
discussion today but look at how many
people go working from from FBI dojcia
NSA and their next job is in Silicon
Valley it's a huge percentage Yeah if
you remove the the immunities of what
they did in tobacco companies then
you're thinking maybe the or or might
what happened is they won't prosecute
properly because they want to get jobs
there even if they don't have what I've
seen so far is that the folks at doj
want to be like just enough of a
parasite that never kills the host so
you know they want to be just enough of
a pain where they maximize their own
economic value to then go and work for
the big tech companies afterwards
man that's a good question would we use
the government to break it up or just
strip their immunity and let the law
take take this course and this is the
issue that Jim Jordan and I disagree on
you know guy as we've talked about I
have tremendous respect for but he
prefers more of a Judicial route and I
prefer more of a legislative route I I
prefer the government stop controlling
big Tech social media and stop
manipulating the platform for their own
personal benefit that's me and I think
if we stop that and and we also have to
understand the government allowed these
companies to have a monopoly on the
market there's no way to even compete
against them because of the unfair
advantage that they got from members of
Congress and and and whether it's tax
incentives whether it's Google Maps
getting the data from the US military
there's there's so much of of them just
working hand in hand that I don't even
see the big difference between you know
big Tech social media and the government
sometimes to be honest with you well big
Tech is owned by someone like government
at least is we the people but I I do but
they're still acting like a vehicle or
for the private so Matt
is it is it still we the people with
government
I I think members of Congress should
have to wear the patches of their pack
and lobbyist donors like NASCAR drivers
have to wear their sponsors yeah I think
Bill Hicks made that joke originally and
he was prophetic and I absolutely agree
with him 100 we should do like an
augmented reality VR app or ar app where
you put on the glasses and you can see
like the augmented reality of all the
donors on other clubs you can see the
lobby standing behind them yeah with
their hands on there like in an aura
just like floating above you see like
big Pharma big Tech defense contractors
that's actually a joke meme that came
out but is very very should should be
like on their desk you should see all
the all the people that have donated to
their behavior because they're supposed
to represent their 700 000 constituents
well it's the most insulting thing when
you go try to persuade someone to change
their Viewpoint or to develop their
Viewpoint and they literally refer you
to the lobbyists like I've had that
happen with colleagues where I'm like
hey look I really want to talk to you
about this insurance issue and they're
like okay great as soon as I hear from
the State Farm in all state lobbyists
that like your change is an appropriate
one then I can be with you that sounds
like
you mentioned before the show that
people pay each other for sponsorship
well I was discussing the dynamic on the
house floor so on the floor of the House
of Representatives members enjoy broad
immunities as a consequence of the
speech and debate clause and giving each
other political donations to campaigns
is permissible on the floor and so I
mean you can observe Dynamics where
someone is
in one sentence soliciting your Vote or
co-sponsorship and then in the very next
sentence is talking is handing you a
check thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time